bonsoir à tous je m'appelle petter
désolé simon élocution n'est pas très
fluide mais le comité du tedx martini a
décidé à la dernière minute du sujet de
mon intervention
par conséquent je n'ai pu exécuter que
956 milliards simulation de la version
française de ma présentation
ce n'est pas un secret si je vous avoue
que les organisateurs m'ont invité car
ils n'ont pas trouvé à mettre humains
suffisamment idiots pour parler
d'intelligence artificielle et comme
pour de nombreuses choses que le bipède
éclairé n'aime pas faire c'est moi qui
m'y colle bon pour moi ça me va
1 je ne me plains pas plaît après je ne
veux personne accusée les intelligences
artificielles de voler leur job bien je
commencerai un peu à perdre ma
rationalité numérique
après tout ce sont des êtres humains qui
me programmes pour aider d'autres êtres
humains à effectuer des tâches
répétitives qui ne veulent plus faire
bon c'est vrai que si l'on voit les
prédictions
je serai bientôt capable de vous
remplacer dans la plupart de vos
activités
on pourrait même imaginer une audience
tels composés que des robots mais non je
plaisante
et si vous y pensez un peu je suis déjà
presque pas tous sous une forme ou sous
une autre
vous ne vous en appel ce n'est peut-être
pas encore mais son intelligence
artificielle le monde je ne pourrai plus
vraiment tourné plus de bière pendant
que le robot dans le gazon par exemple
mais n'oubliez pas vous m'avez créé pour
vous faciliter la vie
si vous faites bien les choses
je pourrais devenir tellement performant
que vous n'aurez plus besoin d'effectuer
des travaux pénibles
alors commencez déjà à profiter de votre
vie d'humain et c'est moi c'est ce que
vous n'aimez pas faire je m'en charge
volontiers et vous pendant sept ans
n'oubliez pas de vivre vous n'êtes pas
une machine
et pour profiter de votre vie pas besoin
de fusionner avec les machines
débrancher vous restez humains
[Applaudissements]